leave motivation what's your total of
elimination hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to have
a strong why don't fear failures and
make sacrifices with Elon Musk and my
take on his top ten rules to success
volume 5 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a strong why the president's
first space policy directive to me it
was go to the man and the wording there
is sustainable reusability is
fundamental the if you've got a fully
reusable vehicle will cost a 100 times
less for flight than an expendable
vehicle I've said Colonel about money at
all but I do care about us becoming
spacefaring civilization yeah and I do
though that if we don't actually pull
her up reusability will not happen and
so that's why that's the only reason
actually you've won one money at all
what I really want to see is you know
I'm gonna face on moon on the moon
permanently occupied human based on the
moon
and us building city on Mars that's like
I could see the baby beginning of that
before I die I'll die happy rule number
two don't fear failure we got to try to
create an electric car company but it
wasn't as though in creating these
companies that we thought that we would
be successful I thought that the most
likely outcome was failure but but it
was still worth doing even though the
odds of success were low in fact in full
force for spacex the originally what I
started doing was not creating a rocket
company but but actually was gonna do a
small mission to Mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where we would
send a small green house with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the board upon landing
hydrate the gel and you'd have this cool
picture of green plants on a red
background and the public tends to
respond to precedents and superlatives
so this we the first life on Mars where
this the life's ever traveled and you'd
have this great money shot of green
plants on the right background and so
yeah I thought that would get people's
attention so but but the expectation for
that was was no return so the expect I
thought we wouldn't get any you know
we'll just spend the money on that and
it wouldn't wouldn't happen
rule number three use physics principles
in your thinking and the way I tend to
view problems this is from it from a
physics standpoint and I think I think
physics is a good analytical framework
and one of the key things in physics is
to reason from first principles this is
contrary to the way most human reasoning
takes place which is by analogy
reasoning from first principles just
means that you figure out what are the
fundamentals what are the fundamental
truths or or things that are pretty
people are pretty sure of fundamental
truths and and can you build up to a
conclusion front from that are uniform
those principles and and then certainly
if you come up with some idea and it
appears to violate one of those
fundamental truths and you're probably
wrong or you should get a really big
prize or something like that so this may
seem like I don't know maybe it may seem
sort of obvious when it's explained but
it's actually not what people do
you reasoning my analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut
yeah and it's mostly correct but but it
tends to be most incorrect when you're
dealing with new things because it's
hard to analogize to something really
new rule number four make sacrifices
well I mean Tesla really faced this fear
threat threat of death due to the model
3 production ramp essentially the
company was bleeding money like crazy
and and just if we didn't solve these
problems in a very short period of time
we would die and was extremely difficult
to solve them how close to death did you
found we're within single digit weeks
22 hours a day I think what I mean I was
working answer seven days a week
sleeping in the factory worked away from
the I worked in the paint shop general
assembly body shop you ever worry about
yourself imploding like it's just very
much absolutely no one should put the
spenny hours into work this is not good
you feel should not work this hard I
don't look they should not do this it
was very painful painful in what sense
it's because my hurts my brain in my
heart also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below there are times when
if something is important enough you
believe in it enough but you do it in
spite of fear rule number five take
risks he started with a much smaller rod
it's often one
and was your goal at that point when you
started with punkin one to get to the
point where we had neither
good night without your goal in that
life when I started SpaceX I only
thought goes maybe in the 10% chance of
getting someone to open I do not all
think that this would happen as this is
for sure great come through but I meant
anything about rockets and I was they
are going to chief engineer of space a
since day one and I know there anything
that Rockets which is why the first
three rockets failed okay
and then so the first three Falcon ones
for space sector of failures yes and
then tell me about the fourth one so I
had actually only had enough money for
Eagle three flights so that no more
money of that through nice
the teams that are proudly and we nicely
put together enough spare parts potato
to do a fourth floor and that fourth
floor was successful and and then what
what would have happen if it wasn't
successful
oh we're SpaceX for the night so we
would not be here right now at this
moment getting ready to launch fruit
dragon to the internet is rule number
six asked the right questions when you
were in college developing these skills
you want to do some things that were of
benefit to humanity that why why did you
think that well because not everyone
does yeah no I I guess it was sort of a
existential crisis of like what does it
all mean and what's the mini you know
what's the meaning of life and there's 3
a.m. over a beer or probably goes back
to high school I guess I don't to give a
lavoris the long answer but I was sort
of a dark childhood it wasn't good
probably partially brought on but by
reading some of the fluff is like don't
ever read Schopenhauer Nietzsche if
you're fourteen that's it's not good now
or Iran either yeah yeah so it's just
trying to find figure out what you know
what as well mean and actually when I
read The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy I think it's a great work
philosophy that sort of highlight at the
point that very often the issue is
understanding what questions to ask and
if you can properly frame the question
then the answer is the easy part
so I thought things that expand the
scope and scale of human consciousness
and allow us to better ask questions and
you know and and and achieve greater
enlightenment
those are good things and so that's sort
of what can we do that's gonna most
likely lead to that outcome rule number
seven disrupt the industry back in 95
they weren't very many people on the
internet and certainly nobody was making
any money at all most people thought the
internet was gonna be
a fad a year ago musk sold his software
company zip to which enabled newspapers
to publish online for 400 million
dollars cash receiving cash is cash I
mean those are just a large number of
Ben Franklin's so this is an ATM what
we're gonna do is transform the
traditional banking industry I do not
fit the picture of a banker raising 50
million dollars is a matter of making a
series of phone calls and the money is
there I've sunk the great majority of my
net worth interacts calm which is the
new banking and mutual funds company on
the internet that I've started I think
XCOM could absolutely be a multi-billion
dollar bonanza because if you look at
the industry that X is pursuing it's the
biggest sector of the world economy and
what you've got going on with the
Internet is it's basically like an
earthquake where the epicenter is
Silicon Valley and it's it's shaking up
the whole world rule number eight have
people you admire
you've been compared to Henry Ford
Richard Branson you know Steve Jobs who
do you compare yourself to I mean I
don't really compare myself to anyone I
mean it's not there's certain people
that I admire from history that I think
are you know I think a great certainly
many of the scientists and engineers and
buttery figures and so forth and like
I'm a big big fan of Benna Franklin you
know there's a scientist and sort of
thinker and he was kind of guys who did
it did what needed to be done you know
so I what guys like that I write
wouldn't say I compare myself in any way
but I certainly admire them rule number
nine pushed the frontier so I think part
of the problem with the reason people
aren't as excited about space is that we
haven't been pushing the frontier as
much and so you can only you can only
watch the same movie so many times and
it before it gets a little boring and
you know in the 60s and early 70s we're
really pushing the frontier of human
spaceflight
and announcer that those land landing on
the moon is regarded as one of the
greatest achievements of humanity of
arguably of life itself and even though
only a handful of people went to the
moon vicariously we all went there well
at least I wasn't alive at the time sir
but retrospectively and you know and it
was it was just one of those really
inspiring things that I think made
everyone glad to be a you know human you
know it's like the things that we were
you know if they're bad things human
ideas and they're they're good things
and that's one of the good things and I
do think it's important that we have
these inspiring things that you make you
glad to get up in the morning and and
that that and glad to be a member of
human race and we need we need to push
that that that frontier so and I think
the great goal we should be trying to
pursue is trying to make life human make
make life multiplanetary so to establish
a self-sustaining and growing
civilization on another planet Mars
being the only realistic possibility and
and I think that would just be one of
the greatest things humanity could ever
try to do and you'll number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
make things happen from the first
explorers who ventured off our planet to
those who have risked their lives and
pursued to furthering our understanding
of the universe the astronauts and
engineers behind the u.s. space program
have spent decades advancing space
technology but building rockets was
expensive by the early 2000s the u.s.
space program was struggling
and a mission to Mars was hard to
imagine Space Shuttle spreads its wings
one final time for the start of a
Sentimental Journey into history it was
then that a young entrepreneur had a
revolutionary idea
[Music]
with SpaceX what we're trying to do is
achieve a huge advancement in rocket
technology if you look at rocket
technology it actually got worse over
time in 1969 we were able to go to the
moon and then with the Space Shuttle we
were only able to go to low-earth orbit
and then with a space shuttle went away
and then we weren't able to go to orbit
from the United States so like that's a
negative trend line it's not like you
can extrapolate that trend line into the
future and it gets good it's a trend
line to zero so if it's not gonna come
from the government
then it's got to come from a private
company now I have a special bonus clip
from elan on how to hire the right
people that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what item on your to-do list do you just
need to make happen number two what is
the failure that you need to stop
fearing and number three what is your
strong why and if you promise to take
action after watching this video we
don't just watch videos anymore we do
something after watching them give me a
hash tag believe down the comments make
that promise to yourself and then get to
work I've made several hiring decisions
in the past which where I valued
intellect over heart and I think that
was a mistake and so try to try to
adjust accordingly you know that it
actually matters whether somebody's good
person beyond just you know goodness
itself
if you want ten more success rules from
Elon Musk's check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the one thing I couldn't compress
was the cost launched because there only
a few options and the us options are way
too expensive and they ended up going to
Russia three times to try to buy